i
cannot
forgive the cruelty and the gaslighting
and the theft of my childhood
but i absolutely
do not need to live in like live there
anymore and move past it like i'm
talking about it a lot now right i i
have talked about this more in the last
two months than i have in the last 10
years uh it's just part of this whole
process right yeah um
and um
i
uh
i have worked really hard
to not let this be the thing that like
is constantly buzzing around my head
like i've described my anxiety as a
little swarm of bees that's kind of
always around my head right and
sometimes they're really loud and
they're really swarming and other times
they're like super cool and relaxed yeah
yeah but they're always there
they're always there and they're always
ready to swarm and go bananas like
that's just part of you know the way my
brain takes care of itself
um
uh like all of this stuff is just it's
gonna be part of me no matter what and i
have to think about like what am i going
to do and how am i going to move forward
with all of this i don't forgive it
because it's unforgivable
like it's in the book i don't want to
talk about it because it's really
upsetting and re-traumatizing but it's
in the book
they participated in my sister and me
being abused on the set of a movie they
allowed it to happen they did not take
us off the set they did not protect us
they failed in the number one
responsibility that parents have for
children which is to protect them and
keep them safe
and they didn't they
sold me to
this production company
uh and and then just kind of threw my
sister in all also like because they
wanted the money and my mom wanted a
trip
right
it's
it's unforgivable stuff it's just it's
terrible inexcusable things
traumatic moments that like for decades
i was like i really need to talk about
this thing that happened on the set of
this movie because it was super
upsetting to me and the way that mom
would reply to it was well that was
really hard for all of us
oh okay i'm sure it was really hard for
you as a woman in her 30s and an adult
who's not being forced to work three
units at the same time when they're 13
um and and they're being like
regularly abused by by like the director
of the movie um uh
i'm sure it was really hard on you it
all becomes about her
it always goes back to them all of it
and i write about this too there's a
thing in the book where i directly
address her and i say like listen i
really want to believe so much that part
of you is saying
oh my god
i gotta
i just hadn't thought about it this way
or like not capable or like yes that
that is or i'm sorry or whatever but the
reality is the woman i knew for 46 years
is just so heavily invested in her
victim narrative